parliament votes on new copyright rules  the regulations should better protect  artists authors and creatives while  ensuring that rules that apply in the  real world  also apply online more than 80 of marine  litter is plastic  meps are set to approve new rules  banning single-use plastics like  drinking straws plates and cotton buds  from 2021.  parliament is committed to promoting  clean and affordable energy for all  members vote on new measures to make the  electricity market greener  and more consumer-friendly following  recent financial scandals parliaments is  set to adopt the recommendations of its  tax committee  proposals include improving tax  cooperation between member states  and setting up a european financial  police force  parliament examines new plans to improve  the quality of tap water across the eu  members want to reduce pollutants such  as lead and bacteria  and improve access to drinking water in  public spaces